two questions number one why is Mel
Gibson fighting a beaver puppet - how
did this movie get made the beaver is a
2011 dark comedy about depression
it is so pitch black dark it's basically
a drama with a talking beaver puppet the
movie was not a hit it was a failed
comeback attempt for Mel Gibson after
any semitic tirades duis and the
allegations of abuse but you can't
forget that this movie is deeply
unflinchingly weird it got made at a
time when the top ten movies at the box
office were all parts of larger
franchises you guys really look great
how did this happen
allow me to briefly explain if you go to
screenwriter Kyle Killens blogspot law
there's a clue a post from December 11
2008 called blacklisted that's because
in 2008 kyle Killen landed on the top of
the blacklist
since 2005 a survey called the blacklist
has recorded the most liked unproduced
screenplays bouncing around Hollywood
industry insiders submit their favorite
unproduced screenplays and then the
anonymous votes are tallied and
published it's that simple but it's
quickly become a huge source of buzz and
it's based on scripts alone and by
looking at a blacklist success you can
learn something about how all these
movies from number one to number 216
actually get me
[Music]
when Franklin Leonard started his
blacklist survey he didn't have a master
plan just a big idea you have a much
greater chance of making a great movie
with a great script than you do if you
don't have one so he started something
in December 2005 the blacklist started
as a survey my job was I was working for
the entire DiCaprio's film production
company my job was to find great scripts
I felt like I was doing a very bad job
at my job I want to do a better job I
sent an email to 75 of my peers and said
send me a list of your 10 favorite
screenplays that haven't yet been
produced and in exchange I will send you
to combine lists they all go get my put
it all on a spreadsheet at the table
output a PowerPoint with a quasi
subversive name on it to blacklist
it was a reference both to the Hollywood
blacklist of McCarthy era and the
conscious inversion of the notion that
blacks somehow need to signify bad and
sit it out I think that the blacklist or
liquid is come into existence at the
time minifig first blacklist went viral
the same weekend that lazy Sunday went
viral from Saturday Night Live the way
in which you consume information online
and the way in which we share
information online that was I think the
beginning of that moment where like all
those relationships and all of sort of
what we were comfortable with in terms
of sharing information for better or
worse started changing suddenly a list
of great stories could show up in one
place and be distributed around the
world thanks to the internet that 2005
blacklist included future hit movies
like Juno but to understand its real
influence you have to go beyond the list
let's say getting a movie made requires
a certain amount of buzz let's make the
metaphor really literal here take 2011
stop movie Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part-2 it's a franchise last one
was a hit it has huge stars there's no
question about buzz it gets me now
imagine a movie like the beaver I think
it's important to remember that every
year there are something like 50,000
screenplays registered at the Writers
Guild every year if you are a
particularly industrious reader
maybe you'll read a thousand screenplays
the year so obviously there's a gap of
some 49,000 scripts just in that single
year that are submitted to Hollywood
generally that you're not going to read
now the beaver was not plucked from
nowhere
Kyle killin had representation and it
had been picked up by a production
company
Steve Carell was even attached before
the 2008 blacklist came out but this
movie was not Harry Potter winning the
blacklist made the buzz public and at
the same time sustained that buzz
through actor and director changes it
kept going until a movie about a talking
beaver puppet improbably miraculously
actually got made we just say send us a
list of your favorite screenplays that
haven't yet been produced you end up
with a list that includes everyone from
Aaron Sorkin and David Benioff and
people who literally this is their first
screenplay and they've just arrived in
Hollywood or they're still living
outside in LA Kyle Gillan was not yet a
Hollywood insider but the blacklist
clearly helped his movie keep buzzing
dissecting hype his hard take 2012's
Argo it got 28 votes on the 2010
blacklist it already had a reputation it
was based on a great 2007 Joshua Berman
wired article optioned by George Clooney
they got former CIA agent Tony Mendez
involved so it had energy but the buzz
kind of leveled off then after the 2010
blacklist came out Ben Affleck decided
to direct the blacklist didn't make Argo
or Juno happen but it got the scripts
noticed it didn't single-handedly green
like the hundreds of movies its featured
some you've heard of some you habit but
it has amplified buzz that isn't about
big stars and amusement park ride
adaptations toy friendly sequels or
superhero franchises its buzz about
words stories
[Music]
today the blacklist is a well-oiled
machine including its own podcasts
events and online submission network and
it's all focused on generating hype
about writing I know when I am leading a
good script because the rest of the
world ceases to exist
and when you're finished you're a little
sad because you don't get to spend any
more time in that world than with those
characters the beaver was not a
box-office hit it ended up in 216th
place in 2011 the Rotten Tomatoes rating
61 percent fine but not great in the
beginning of the beaver there's a scene
where Mel Gibson is about to walk back
to his car and drive home but then he
stops Mel sees something mangy and weird
in the pile of trash he pulls the beaver
out and then everything changes
you
[Music]
you